الحرب في اوكرانيا تقترب من اتمام عامها
الاول تطورات ميدانيه تراوحت بين التقدم
والاخفاق على صعيد الجيشين لكن ما هو شبه
ثابت ان الرئيس الروسي ضلاديمير بوتين فشل
في تحقيق اي من اهدافه الرئيسيه التي خطط
لها منذ اليوم الاول بحسب تحليل اجرته
مجله
التحليل اشار الى ان بوتين لم يوحدوا
الامه الواحده المزعومه ولم ينزع سلاح
اوكرانيا ولم يوقف توسع النيتو ليس هذا
فحسب بل تلقت قواته ضربات قاسيه وخسائر
ميدانيه كبيره وفقا للمجله الجيش
الاوكراني في المقابل استطاع ان يبقي
القوات الروسيه خارج العاصمه كياب حتى
الان ودفع عن ثاني اكبر مدينه في اوكرانيا
كما اطلق هجمات مضاده ناجحه في الخريف حرر
بها اكثر من 50% من الاراضي التي استولى
عليها الجنود الروس سابقا
مشاهدينا في ظل كافه التطورات التي تشهدها
الحرب في اوكرانيا لم تشق مفاوضات السلام
طريقها على خط هذا الصراع بعد بل كل
المؤشرات تصب بانها ستكون حربا طويله
الامد سيام وان روسيا تخطط لشد هجوم واسع
من بعد اشهر قليله او ما اطلق عليه معركه
الربيع فيما يواصل الغرب امداد اوكرانيا
بالدعم العسكري
[موسيقى]